Calvin Harris speaks out publicly on his  romance with taylor swift for the first  time while covering the latest issue of  british GQ the 32 year old producer says  their breakup was more public than their  actual relationship when we were  together we were very careful for it not  to be a media circus she respected my  feelings in that sense but the fallout  of their relationship was not quite the  same The Scotsman admitted it's very  difficult when something I consider so  personal plays out very publicly it's he  alluding to Taylor subsequent romance  with Tom Hiddleston or the Twitter fire  that transpired in July over his single  this is what you came for regardless  Harris is pretty straightforward about  it all and confesses for both of us it  was the wrong situation it clearly  wasn't right so it ended